(crowd chatters)
(slow inspirational music)
- [Narrator] These women
are some of the most
badass athletes you've ever seen.
My name's Kelly Cantwell.
I'm also known as Momster Mash.
In my previous life, I
was an HR professional
and now I'm a roller skating instructor
for the Kansas City Roller Warriors
and an aspiring Roller Derby Girl.
(calm music)
- [woman] Alright, guys, come and eat.
- Being a mom is a very interesting job.
My husband is Chris,
then we have two boys,
Emerson and Elliott.
That's the four of us.
We are very busy.
I had this super stressful, crazy
hectic more than full-time job working
as a Director of HR for a nonprofit.
I always thought that
roller derby would be
an awesome way to like
let out some aggression.
(crowd chatters)
But we started having kids.
Then I heard about this
program that was like
fitness skating.
It was drills and skills
based on roller derby,
but no impact with other skaters
so there's no risk of injury,
and I absolutely fell in love with it.
Then Chris accepted the job to teach here
and I started up the
local Kansas City branch
of that group.
I still remember when we bought a Subaru.
We were expecting
Emerson, we wanted to get
something a little bigger
that felt a little safer.
When I think of Subaru, I do
think of an active lifestyle.
People are using their
Subarus to go skiing
or go hiking or go play
ice hockey or roller derby.
We've always got bags of gear in the back.
We got ice hockey gear for Emerson,
my roller derby bag.
That's just how we roll.
(calm instrumental music)
When I brought Derby Lite here with me,
I knew no one.
I had to reach out to rinks.
I had to find people who
would want to do this
like new skating program.
When I was in HR, it was something
that I definitely took
home with me at night.
It was really hard on my family.
Now, I get to do something
I absolutely love,
like I'm passionate about
it and I'm hanging out
with friends.
(team cheers)
When skaters have completed
their Learn to Skate classes,
they can go to their
Warriors in Training program,
which is then how they get drafted
to be on a competitive league team.
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentlemen, let's take...
- I'm actually signed up to start
the Warriors in Training
program next month
so hopefully in a couple of months
you'll be able to see Momster Mash as part
of one of the local home teams.
That just made it really
official saying that to you
right now with all these cameras.
(classical music)
The challenge is just
staying more connected
when things feel super busy.
Even with things that we
love, I want to make sure
that we are still moving
forward with all of us
with our goals.
We'll just keep going after what we love
and make sure that we're
cheering each other on.
- Go Emerson.
- [Kelly] Yeah, the sky's the limit.